right we are at Starling battle for
Atlas we're gonna check out some
gameplay going on these fine gentlemen
have allowed me to fill them for science
[Music]
also this is like all involved with it's
always
okay
oh how nice nice
all right so we getting the
customization going
[Music]
oh wow please legit has his ship
customized while he's playing that's
pretty cool
so for someone that's Loula snarling
what well how would you describe the
game
[Music]
[Music]
very cool love the scope of the game
[Music]
yeah I did hear that uh there is a some
Starbucks characters from integration as
well right nice
[Music]
nice
most visible - it
[Music]
okay okay nice nice
[Music]
gotcha
so you have that hops again they're not
they're not locked in to having a body
so I just - that's good okay guys you
got to be cool with that way you take it
off all awesome which is the advantage
of percentage in my opinion
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
right now did you enjoy it man you're
joining us it was fun definitely
different different from what I had okay
[Music]
all right he's a fan man you heard it
here first start starlings like the fun
out here thank you so much thank you
[Music]